president biden was making an urgent
case for voting rights this evening
calling for an exception to senate
filibuster rules as a reminder the
filibuster allows for legislation delays
typically from the minority party in
order to block anything that can't get
up to 60 votes and there was criticism
about his speech today that grew after
several voting rights groups decided to
skip it we're speaking with an
individual from one of those
organizations now latasha brown is the
co-founder of black voters matter fun
and she joins us now latasha thank you
for joining us on quick take i know i
just mentioned you're part of one of the
organizations that chose not to attend
the speech after hearing it do you stand
by that decision
no i think it was the right decision
because i think our point was not to be
let we decided the groups in georgia
that decided not to attend the meeting
we were not we didn't decide because we
wanted to be antagonistic or combative
to the president matter of fact we want
him to actually get this done what we
wanted to do is send a message loud and
clear that this is a serious moment for
us that we feel like a lot of time has
been squandered that we are now at this
moment he himself in his own speech said
that he's been silent long enough that
as a result we feel like we've lost a
lot of momentum and a lot of time and
this is the moment right now that
literally we need more than speeches
that what we need is we need true
commitment and action yeah i i was
actually happy to hear several of the
things that he said in the speech today
but part of the reason why we didn't
attend today is because we said there
were a couple of things one we wanted to
hear
you know it wasn't just a matter of just
hearing what his belief was around
voting rights what we want is we wanted
to know a real clear path forward we
wanted to hear an action plan around how
can we move forward to make sure that
there's a full commitment from the white
house to support voting rights
legislation in this nation what
specifics did you hear in his speech
that made you feel like there is a clear
plan moving forward because he did cite
a lot of the division making it hard to
to get this done
you know one of the things that
activists um and organizers like myself
have been talking about for months now
for months we have we have
met we've gone to the white house we've
expressed this going to the white house
we've met at we went to the senate we've
gone to the house we've met with the
senate leadership the house leadership
we've sent letters to the president
we've we've done everything we've
protested we've been arrested around the
filibuster that for over a year what we
have close to a year we have been saying
that there was no path forward without a
consideration to actually be able to a
man carve out eliminate or whatever you
had to do around the filibuster what was
hopeful that i think was a part of a
plan that i heard from him today was
that he was he has now
publicly expressed which is
distinctively different than what he has
his position has been in recent months
is that he is willing not he is willing
for there to be a carve out or a change
of the rules so that we can move forward
um in spite of the filibuster that he
himself actually called for that and so
i think that was hopeful i think that
that was probably one of the most
significant things that he said in the
speech today sure but he also is dealing
with two democratic senators of course
joe manchin and kirsten cinema who are
not necessarily going to change their
views on the filibuster it's going to be
hard to get them on board
if you were the president what would
your strategy be to get these two
democrats on board with changing the
filibuster so that voting rights can get
pushed through you know i think that
this has to be almost a critical issue i
hope that he continues to weigh in on
this and and literally dig in i hope
that he continues to literally uh call
those senators put continue to put
pressure on them to use what he can use
within the context of his presidential
power i mean some of that he alluded to
today in the speech i'm hoping that he
does that that he actually leverages the
full weight of his office of president
to put pressure on them so that
literally there's a spotlight you know
it's noticeable that he did not call
them out by name and i think that
there's still a space around trying to
negotiate with them you know i have very
very little faith in and particularly
senator madison at this point because i
think he's been extremely disingenuous
and dishonest the entire time which many
of us um feared from the beginning why
why we were calling for the voting
rights um legislation to be a priority
before even build back better or the
infrastructure bill we felt that he was
saying that at the time because he had a
vested interest but not because that he
was actually interested in anyway this
is
center mansion in supporting the voting
rights legislation so i think that
there's a number of things what what i
think what the president reminded us
today that he has a significant history
and um in the senate and that there's an
expectation of someone who who spent
four decades in the senate that i'm
quite sure that there are ways that that
i am hoping that he will use every
pressure point that is available to him
to actually push and to bring those
those senators and hold them accountable
to this their their party to hold them
accountable to the people in this nation
let's talk about the other side here
let's talk about the republicans and
what these restrictions look like
obviously a lot of gerrymandering in
georgia itself if we look in texas
republicans tried to make it easier for
election results to be overturned that
was stopped after democrats had a
walkout i mean there's absentee ballot
limitations tightening of id
requirements the list goes on all of
this revved up after the 2020 election
results why do you think that voting
rights has become such a political
football for republicans
you know i don't think that it's just a
political football i think it's a
strategy i think that they have an
active
con strategy and a concerted effort to
undermine the democratic process that
this is what we're seeing as the best
case scenario we've seen this how
democracies have died all around the
world that this is a best case scenario
for a a minority to actually want to
control the politics of a majority that
the bottom line is they are not they do
not have an agenda that has been
appealing to the majority of americans
of people in this country of different
nationalities different social nomic
backgrounds that literally can actually
for them to hold on to power so what
they've decided instead is that they're
going to cheat that they are willing to
blow up whatever element of democracy in
this country so that a few people could
actually maintain their power and their
positioning i think we have to treat it
as such we can't treat this as this
voting rights issue is just another
policy issue this is another bill that
the republicans and democrats disagree
oh no this is a fundamental issue that
changes the nature and the character of
this democracy in this nation
latasha really appreciate you joining us
and explaining that thank you so much
that was latasha brown co-founder of
black voters matter fund joining us to
talk about president biden's speech on
changing up the filibuster